[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
avec à la une cette semaine l'enjeu de
la vidéosurveillance les caméras sont
présents partout dans nos rues même les
campagnes n'y échappe pas pour assurer
la sécurité des biens et des personnes
un reportage de moselle télévision à
suivre dès le début de ce journal il ya
plus de 150 ans et promet un voyage dans
le temps à tous ceux qui en jouent un
piano de 1859 est actuellement utilisée
par le conservatoire de limoges une
expérience musicale extraordinaire que
nous racontera la rédaction de 7 à
limoges extraordinaire aussi la
palmeraie du sarthou dans le gères qui
conduit ses visiteurs dans une
expérience floral et exotique un espace
naturel de 10 hectares à découvrir en
fin de journal avec la dépêche du midi
notre partenaire des images superbes
garantie est devenu difficile d'échapper
vous en croiserez sûrement durant vos
vacances d'été les caméras de
surveillance se multiplient sur les
façades des bâtiments publics et dans
nos rues depuis une vingtaine d'année
difficile pour les collectivités de ne
pas céder à cette tendance sécuritaire
et si les villes restent bien sûr les
plus surveillés les villages et les
campagnes eux aussi désormais sont
scrutés exemple en moselle avec ce
reportage de jean mi longs pour moselle
télévision la chaîne locale sur place
et c'est ici qu effectivement avant la
pause et cameron avaient
systématiquement un mois seulement de
tout de rien ben surpris des gens
essayer de rentrer des sceaux à coups de
pieds dans ces collecteurs de papier
donc ça pouvait pas continuer
aujourd'hui on l'a retrouvé un site qui
est propre suite aux incivilités à
répétition ce maire a décidé d'investir
dans la vidéo surveillance depuis 2000
vingt trois caméras ont été installés
dans des endroits stratégiques du
village
la liberté de là s'arrête là où commence
celle de l'autre ce trailer plus moxos
pas respectés et pour justement
respecter ce proverbe la commune
comptant pourtant moins de 1000
habitants va continuer à investir
néanmoins il existe bel et bien un bémol
le maire redoute un déplacement du
problème dans les villages voisins
c'est pour cette raison qu ici à woippy
une police intercommunale a été créé en
2006 car la ville est suréquipée à
l'heure actuelle elle compte 148 caméra
soit une pour environ 70 habitants un
ratio plus élevé qu'à nice la référence
française en terme de vidéoprotection
mais je présume que s'était posé au coût
que ça doit coûter c'était une raison
valable c'est beaucoup plus sécurisant
surtout pour les enfants quand ils
rentrent à l'école qui rentre à pied ce
genre de choses là en fait c'est plus
sécurisant de savoir que si jamais ils
rencontrent un problème quelconque en
fait ils soient surveillés entre guinée
ont froid que cela serve à quelque chose
sur le plan sécurité par contre sur le
plan à la liberté individuelle
je trouve que son gros ce gros ce
costaud sur cette problématique
justement la ville est très rigoureuse
seul le domaine public et surveiller ses
définis dès le départ dès l'installation
des caméras les zones qui sont de
l'issue du du privé et donc forcément ne
sont pas on va lien n'est enregistrée ni
vu et on ne peut pas retirer ces filtres
et six infractions il y a elle doit être
constatée en flagrant délit par
l'opérateur sinon il faut demander une
réquisition aux forces de l'ordre on
voit quand l'espace à peu près de dix
ans nous avons divisé par onze le nombre
de délinquants sur la commune et les
caméras mais bien sûr l'ensemble des
équipes qui font partie de la police
municipale ont permis on va dire de
pouvoir diminuer et diviser ces chiffres
récemment le conseil municipal de woippy
a voté son budget d'ici fin 2022 la
ville comptera près de 200 caméras des
dispositifs qui seront d'ailleurs encore
plus sophistiquée avec par exemple des
alertes automatiques lors d'infractions
au code de la route
les technologies et le numérique à la
portée de tous écrit un sms jouer en
ligne ou tout simplement passer un appel
des gestes ordinaires pour la majorité
d'entre nous mais qui peuvent être un
défi pour des personnes malvoyantes ou
non voyantes pour les aider et les
accompagner dans leurs démarches une
association de la sarthe propose des
ateliers adaptés aux reportages
d'anthony python pour lm tv sarthe
regard des phrases
4 approfondir la frappe de l'alphabet 3
pour les malvoyants accéder à
l'informatique n'est pas toujours simple
christina travail sur un logiciel
vocaliser comme à vue a baissé récemment
en fait je cherchais à me réadapter et
du coup à chercher ou plutôt des
adaptations vocale pour continuer de
travailler
et deux
et pour mon quotidien
concrètement elle apprend l'utilisation
du clavier comme dactylo une première
étape avant d'utiliser des applications
qui permettent de communiquer à l'écrit
les gens viennent avec des demandes
particulières certains ça va être juste
de pouvoir téléphoner de pouvoir envoyer
un sms de pouvoir créer un contact et ça
peut aller jusqu'à des utilisations de
loisirs par exemple lire un livre audio
marie thérèse perd progressivement
l'usagé de ses yeux elle est venue en
train depuis alençon pour apprendre à se
servir de son smartphone autrement et on
va continuer à avoir des relations et
tout ça donc il faut premier moyen quoi
encore la peau le moment je me
débrouille encore parce que je vois
encore un petit peu mais c'est sûr que
j'ai intérêt à préparer quoi c'est
justement l'objectif que poursuit le
comité valentin haüy au travers de son
centre de formation
faire en sorte que la vie sociale ne
baisse pas en même temps que la vue est
le fait de roam utiliser de nouveaux
actes qui vont permettre de récupérer de
l'autonomie et bien redonne de la
confiance en soi et ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose d'hyper
important le pôle autonomie est ouvert à
tous les déficients visuels
pouvez contacter l'association au 02 43
24 20h13
d'action la martinique maintenant dans
cette édition pour découvrir
l'initiative originale d'une association
qui a décidé d'ouvrir le monde des
médias aux seniors ti grand moun tv
diffusent des interviews et des
reportages réalisés par des personnes
novices en la matière objectif créer du
lien entre les générations et formé au
numérique les concernés sujet de josé
lechertier pour vient à tv en martinique
regardez
france a toujours voulu connaître le
monde de la télé aujourd'hui elle
incarne le rôle d'une présentatrice
plateau éclairage caméra un micro elle
découvre l'envers du décor j'ai eu cette
possibilité
de scruter
visuel qui fait partie de notre
quotidien donc pour moi c'était tout
naturel tout naturellement que je me
tais
l'association abhisit levée en place les
seniors sur le devant de la scène avec
ce projet ambitieux leur permettre de
créer des reportages des émissions
d'être des acteurs de l'actualité c'est
aussi l'occasion pour ceux recrutés
d'apprendre de nouveaux métiers seront
la partie technique lundi un montage
comment dire le montage du matériel mais
aussi
concrètement sur un logiciel
professionnel pour que l'émission en
fait soit pour l'instant visible sur
youtube place à la pratique mais avant
d'aller sur le terrain et l'équipe
effectue des recherches donner la bonne
information est primordiale
à savoir si cette news ça peut servir
aussi à informer les autres et pour
veiller sur tout le monde daniel il
connaît l'audiovisuel sur le bout des
doigts c'est
[Musique]
que jacinthe d'eau des seniors est géré
ça très réceptifs très passionné
d'ailleurs aussi passionné que les
jeunes et ça c'est très bien c'est de
bon augure parce que contrairement à
l'autre et très haut la retraite restez
à la maison là et viennent
[Musique]
s'amuser l'exercice du jour réalisé un
micro-trottoir dans le bourg du site oui
le challenge relevé avec succès
après la mode des burgers des sushis ou
encore des ramen c'est le poké ball qui
s'invite dans nos assiettes depuis
quelques années les restaurants
spécialisés dans ce plat awaja fleuriste
un peu partout en france comme à nantes
la ville en compte une quinzaine leurs
promesses et vous offrir un repas bon
pour les papilles et bon pour la santé
alors est ce vraiment le cas reportage
sur place de la rédaction de télénantes
regarder pour kawaoka awa bulls et ikoko
meizu bull le point commun de cette
quinzaine de restaurants dans tes le
poker l'idée de base avec d'être sur une
base de riz vinaigré avec des crudités
le concept même venant d'hawaï à la base
c'est de rajouter un fruit donc un
ananas mangue avec du poisson cru ce
restaurant sur l'île de nantes et le
troisième de la marque dans la cité des
ducs ici on fait environ 120 poké par
jour avec seulement cinq salariés un
concept rentable forcément copier série
c'est un concept
marche bien comme je disais qui est un
peu à la mode dernièrement on a vu
beaucoup d'ouvertures sur deux files été
dernier en fait car l'offre de ses
restaurants et prometteuse un plat
complet et équilibré avec des produits
frais et les clients sont convaincus je
trouve que quand je mange ça me fait
quand même du bien ce que je trouve que
c'est sain et les positions ainsi ferait
quand même moi c'est assez simple c'est
santé oms a paris nous faire plaisir
tout en mangeant équilibré alors le poke
et y at-il vraiment ses promesses c'est
assez rassasiant on a des protéines on a
des fibres on a des légumes c'est vrai
que là le niveau 1 des glycémique en est
un c'est au mine de rien parce qu'on a
le riz blanc qui est un peu sur cuit on
a de la mangue ou plutôt de sucre
augmente donc c'est moins intéressant
sur l'énergie sur le long terme c'est à
dire que on peut avoir des petites des
petites hypoglycémie dans l'après-midi
conseils de la diététicienne une base de
quinoa ou de riz noir évitez les sauces
très sucrés ou salés et préférer une
simple huiles végétales quoi qu'il en
soit l'essentiel reste de se faire
plaisir qui a pas d'interdît mais cesser
de manger le plus possible des produits
bruts ou moins industriel possible et là
on est quand même sur des produits bruts
donc c'est plutôt très positif voilà
l'idée pokéball est donc validée et vous
inspirera peut-être pour vos repas cet
été cet été justement parlons-en vous en
profiterez sûrement pour vous détendre
et lire quelques romans resté coincé
dans vos tiroirs peut-être alors rendre
accessible la lecture ou plutôt les
bouquins c'est l'un des objectifs du
bureau satie l'auteur d'une rubrique
littéraire publié sur l'un des sites de
la région paca il brosse ati bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous depuis la très
belle ville de nice alors dites nous
comment vous est venue l'idée de créer
cette rubrique appelée talus quoi
c'est une envie moins qu'une idée parce
que en fait j'avais envie qu'on parle
montant un peu commune on parle entre
amis comme vous parlez aussi un vieil
oncle mon point de vue là encore
un manque un c'est évident un titre un
type qui provoque le désir un bouquin sa
part d'abord occurred le lecteur
lecteurs qui j'en suis certain ce sera
un très content qu'on lui pose cette
question fait madame monsieur le docteur
d'abus quoi
sans vouloir vous paraphraser talus quoi
c'est quoi ivre satie partait lui quoi
c'est d'abord parlé de look un écrit par
des hauteurs de nice et alentours de ma
région la région suscitent également et
surtout
parlé de manière accessible du voka en
tout de trois questions simples
essentiel on embauche cours du titre de
l'histoire et les personnages c'est des
questions auxquelles tout le monde peut
répondre quel que soit son âge et
surtout ses références culturelles avez
vous des projets particuliers pour la
rentrée à des projets vie dans les
prochaines journées le premier c'est que
souvent les gens me disent que mon coeur
de cible ce sont les lecteurs du
dimanche il tord dimanche c'était
personnes qui ne sont pas forcément
n'ont pas le réflexe bouquin en tout cas
régulier qui teste a forcément les
grands auteurs et bien pour ce sélecteur
du dimanche films clips sont à qui il
reste maintenant pour moi à conquérir
les lecteurs les six jours restants
deuxième point s'est également renforcé
la présence de tels quoi dans le 06 en
nouant des partenariats médias radio
télé et magazines avant de se quitter
yves pourriez vous nous donner deux
idées de livres ou plutôt de bouquins
pour cet été j'ai une sélection de deux
genres nul doute qu'un que je vous
invite à découvrir sur mon site ce
seront d'abord quatre villes et leurs
particularités c'est qu'elles sont
publiées par le plus vieil éditeurs à de
la région sud par tamudo et le deuxième
bouquin montrer contextuel parce qu'on
le sait bien
propice à l'amour et bien c'est un petit
bouquin publié par un éditeur car tout
70 ans qui se bat qui ça les éditions du
capitaine
qui a découvert en dépit de christine
fabre qui parlent de manière délicieuse
de l'amour avec un grand a rassurez vous
merci vont satie tous vos conseils
lecture sont à retrouver notamment sur
le site internet le petit niçois
de la littérature à la musique partons à
la découverte d'un instrument historique
un piano steinway fabriqué à new york en
1859 il est actuellement utilisé par les
élèves et les professeurs du
conservatoire de limoges avec une
particularité permettre aux pianistes
contemporains d'entendre la reproduction
des sons imaginer au moment de
l'écriture d'une oeuvre d'instruments
fait l'objet bien sûr de toutes les
attentions des pianistes locaux un
reportage de benjamin delmas pour cet
aliment sur place
des touches d'ivoire patiner une table
d'harmonie sans fin plus que centenaire
ce stand est américain fait puissamment
sonné ce prélude et fugue de jean
sébastien bach
on clavier emilie ancien élève et
musiciennes du conservatoire de boude
pas son plaisir de jouer sur un tel
instrument c'est très agréable de jouer
dessus le son est très différent et le
toucher aussi c'est particulier parce
que en fonction de la tessiture on a des
textures de sont extrêmement différentes
et c'est très enrichissant aussi pour
comprendre comment écrivez les
compositeurs en fonction des époques et
en fonction des des fabricants de piano
en fait moi j'ai comptabilisé il nous
faudrait
et au minimum cinq pianos historique qui
nous permettent de couvrir les périodes
de l'histoire de la musique sortie
d'usiné new yorkaise steinway en 1859 ce
piano a été jouée par des générations de
musiciens accordé par un passionné il
retrouve ses sonorités d'antan l'accord
d'un piano c'est pas une opération qui
consiste à mettre une aiguille au milieu
d'un d'un écran
c'est mettre un corps sonores
en harmonie avec l'univers à un moment
donné dans un lieu donné pour une
personne donnée la corse et rechercher
en permanence au niveau des émotions au
niveau du ressenti la justesse
une chose est sûre les pianos
historiques comme ceux steinway ne
demande qu'à être joué et ce pour
longtemps encore
une belle histoire musicale pour ce
piano historique qui nous conduit
également à bordeaux où la passion pour
la musique se conjugue avec l'amitié il
son radiologue avocat ou informaticiens
et forment ensemble un groupe les blue
note sextet parmi ces amateurs de jazz
jean didier lange disparu il ya quelques
mois et l ancien président des girondins
de bordeaux ce groupe a publié il ya
quelques mois un deuxième album et
christophe rigaud est allé à la
rencontre
il y a quelques mois de jean didier
lange et de son groupe
regardez ce reportage
autant à voir qu'à écouter
toutes les semaines c'est un rituel pour
ces passionnés de jazz ils ont
rendez-vous dans les environs de
bordeaux pour partager leur amour de la
musique ils sont ingénieurs
informaticiens radiologues médecins et
ils entretiennent depuis 13 ans une
amitié musicale sous la houlette de jean
didier lange avocat et ancien président
des girondins bordeaux pour qui le jazz
occupe une grande place dans sa vie
l'amérique ça permet de sortir
complètement complètement de soi c'est
seule chose qui vous tient éveillé
l'année pour pour certains
et c'est la seule chose où on voit pas
passer le temps ou pas donc on peut se
retrouver à 3 heures du matin
très éveillée très excité et on est
toujours envie de jouer quoi donc fait
un truc qui vous fait sortir de vous
même
[Musique]
à
m
au sein du groupe blue note sextet on
retrouve des parcours et des niveaux
musicaux différents mais aussi toutes
les influences mais j'ai beaucoup
accroché avec des gens comme comme tic
au real comme pat metheny
voilà c'est plus c'est plutôt ça facile
s'il ya des gens plus kiffe raymond dans
le danger je suis venu au jazz par le
jazz rock j'ai commencé par écouter ça
car j'étais adolescent et petit à petit
j'ai fait j'ai un peu fait le chemin
inverse c'est à dire que j'ai remonté le
temps et pour le choix des morceaux la
décision est collégiale personne
n'impose rien
aux pauvres chiens qui n'est pas
satisfait du morceau laisse tomber
comment il simplement il n'y a pas de
discussion tout se passe dans la détente
et la bonne humeur si le groupe est
composé de musiciens amateurs ils
viennent pourtant d'enregistrer
récemment leur deuxième album un
aboutissement pour ces amoureux du jazz
jamais j'aurais pu imaginer que j'aurais
pu enregistrer un disque
donc oui c'était une grande fierté
d'attrait n'arrivait enregistrer un
disque puis on a la chance d'avoir
marque qui nous a fait un travail
fantastique jouer ensemble pour partager
et se faire plaisir c'est la principale
motivation de ludovic le dernier arrivé
dans la bande mais cette aventure lui a
surtout permis de progresser là bas
c'est vrai on peuvent être portés on
entend le piano qui va faire ça on
entend un tel qu'ils jouent ça et ça
nous donne des idées ces salles
interactions et donc bas la semaine
d'après on va on va travailler on va
bien on va continuer à rêver c'est de
reproduire les choses et c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça qu'on avance
[Musique]
voilà c'était un hommage à jean didier
lange ancien président des girondins de
bordeaux est leader de ce groupe de
musique de jazz restons dans le
sud-ouest dans ce journal la cité du vin
de bordeaux à queue jusqu'au 28 août une
exposition exceptionnelle consacrée au
thème du vin et de l'alcool dans
l'oeuvre de picasso le génie espagnol a
multipliées tout au long de sa vie les
clins d'oeil aux boissons alcoolisées
plus de 80 oeuvres y sont présentés avec
des prêts exceptionnels des musées
picasso de paris et de barcelone
de quoi donner le tournis avec
modération bien sûr picasso
l'effervescence des formes une
découverte d'alix fourcade pour télé 7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest à bordeaux
ne voyez surtout pas dans l'oeuvre de
picasso la seule évocation des plaisirs
de l'ivresse dans l'effervescence des
formes le peintre espagnol magnifie le
vin et des alcools populaire dans toutes
leurs dimensions le vin c'est un plaisir
de la ville c'est aussi un symbole de la
vie des forces de la vie' et puis
qu'elle soit toujours voulu intensifiés
cet aspect là l'existence dans son
oeuvre à travers finalement toutes les
révolutions formelle qu'il a su susciter
créer et donc pour nous il y avait là
une conjonction entre la fonction du
lieu rappeler ce qu'a été le vin les
civilisations du vin nous sommes les
héritiers et puis l'art de picasso c'est
aussi une culture qui rejoint son
catholicisme une culture qui rejoint
l'héritage des grecs le thème des
bacchanales
le thème des dieux et du juin des dieux
trois ans ont été nécessaires pour
rassembler les 80 tableaux et sculptures
de cette exposition elle montre la place
du vin et des alcools populaire dans le
travail du peintre grâce à des prêts
exceptionnels des musées picasso de
barcelone et paris et de collection
personnelle la cité du vin on a eu
l'idée un an après son ouverture
lors de sa première exposition
artistique en 2010 est la première
exposition artistique a proposé la cité
ça plaise bistrot et avaient d'ailleurs
une heure mais une seule une seule
oeuvre de picasso et l'idée est née de
se dire mais finalement picasso a dû
faire il l'a fait beaucoup de choses
autour du vin et des alcools nous voilà
c'est un projet un petit peu fou qu on
est très content de voir se réaliser
aujourd'hui l'exposition est visible
tous les jours de 10 heures à 19 heures
jusqu'au 28 août
voilà une autre idée de sortie pour vos
vacances d'été dans les yvelines le parc
aux étoiles permet d'en savoir un peu
plus sur l'univers et les astres qui le
composent une initiation à l'astronomie
rendu possible grâce à une exposition et
à l'observation du ciel un reportage
découverte presque la tête dans les
étoiles déjà de la rédaction de tv 78 la
chaîne des civils
observer les étoiles à travers la plus
grande lunette astronomique de france et
contempler les astres c'est possible au
parc aux étoiles deuxième site le plus
haut d'île de france il est situé en
plein coeur de la forêt de l'hautil à
triel-sur-seine sa position lui permet
de s'éloigner de la pollution lumineuse
le musée au sein du parc permet d'en
découvrir un peu plus sur l'astronomie
et l'astronautique grâce à un médiateur
scientifique
la visite se déroule dans cette première
galerie commence il y à peu près
13,5 6 milliards d'années dans ce qu'on
appelle communément big bang
progresse vers la formation des galaxies
des explications sur des phénomènes plus
complexes comme par exemple les trous
noirs ou la formation des systèmes
planétaires la seconde galerie du musée
s'articule autour d'événements majeurs
comme le premier satellite artificiel
spoutnik ou encore l'arrivée de l'homme
sur la lune en 1969 et pour les plus
passionnés la grande lunette
astronomique est ouverte au public
elle permet d'admirer le soleil le jour
ainsi que la lune et les planètes la
nuit sans lune est charles à poil donc
qui a été réalisé
en
1895 atelier gustave eiffel pour là
c'est un instrument exceptionnel
jusque c'est la plus grande menace de
médiation scientifique en france autre
outil cette camionnette nommé léonard en
hommage à leonard de vinci premiers
ingénieurs de france le parc aux étoiles
sillonnent ainsi les yvelines pour
apporter la science en dehors de ses
murs mais audard c'est aussi ce
télescope de type dobson qui nous
permettent d'intégrer des sites
d'observation un peu partout sur notre
territoire rendre accessible
l'astronomie et la science au plus grand
nombre et susciter la curiosité
scientifique dès le plus jeune âge voici
l'ambition du site durant les vacances
scolaires il organise des ateliers
pratiques pour les enfants de 5 à 16 ans
il dispose même de sa propre chaîne
youtube du permettant de vulgariser
certains sujets toujours avec un aspect
ludique
voilà partons pour un voyage exotique
dans le gers pour terminer ce journal
la palmeraie du sarthou offre un
spectacle unique de verdure pour les
visiteurs depuis plus de vingt ans des
milliers de palmiers côtoient bambou
nénuphars et une impressionnante
mosaïque florale comme vous le voyez sur
ces images de nos partenaires de la
dépêche du midi sur place une expérience
étendue sur 10 hectares qui transporte
les visiteurs à l'autre bout de la
planète écoutez ce propos de la
propriétaire du site elle répond aux
questions de clément gaci de la dépêche
du midi le palmier dans l'imaginaire
collectif c'est quand même toujours les
vacances c'est l'évasion c'est les i il
sait les lagons bleus est ici si vous
voulez on a reconstitué un micro un
micro endroit de rêve et les visiteurs
nous sommes très reconnaissants de ça
ils nous le disent souvent ils ont
voyagé c'est très valorisant pour le
travail qu'ils ont accompli ici puisque
ses 40 ans de travail de travail parfois
difficile mais n'entrerez comme bancel
et la voilà de bien belles images pour
terminer cette édition c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]